buster douglas dropping the puck last
night in his hometown of columbus ohio
for the blue jackets buster douglas 30
years ago
yesterday shocked the world knocking out
the invincible mike tyson and those are
the images we saw on sportscenter at the
time remember you didn't have the right
so all you could do was flash this still
frame
i still don't believe it when i see it
now that's mike tyson from punch out
that's the guy you couldn't beat he got
beat by buster douglas and so today's
draft inspired by the 30-year
anniversary of buster douglas beating
mike tyson in tokyo
the draft the best knockouts of the 2019
season i've got the trivia question for
big cat if he gets it right he gets the
first pick okay so buster douglas after
beating mike tyson to become the
heavyweight champion in the world he
would lose the belt later that year in
his very first title defense who beat
buster douglas in his one and only fight
as the heavyweight champion
was it evander holyfield
[Music]
well done got it yeah because it was
supposed to be mike tyson versus
vanderholyfield that was supposed to be
the big fight and it didn't happen uh
you know when both were in their prime
because of this loss and then mike tyson
went to jail
yes and then mike tyson was never quite
the same and it's amazing he was
it was almost no fun to watch him i
remember the michael spinks fight
june of 1988 and and i almost thought
about it those are back in the days when
i had no money at all most thought about
like going to because you would you
could go to an arena and pay to watch it
on closed circuit tv it lasted 90
seconds best money i never spent so
that's how dominant he was it was no fun
he destroyed everybody and then buster
douglas came along all right you get the
first pick best knockouts of the 2019
nfl season okay best knockouts of the
2019 uh nfl season i guess i'll just
start with the most shocking knockout
the knockout that took the best team in
the league during the regular season out
of the playoffs the baltimore ravens
14-2 playing at home against the
tennessee titans team with ryan
tannehill as their quarterback could you
imagine
like week six having that statement said
to you that the baltimore raves are
gonna lose as the one seed to ryan
tannehill and the titans but it happened
and it was crazy and it was shocking and
you know 10 and a half point favorites
were the ravens and everyone thought
that they were this unstoppable offense
and what a game plan by mike frable and
the tennessee titans to keep lamar
jackson you know in the pocket he threw
it what 50 plus times just a great game
plan and they took their shots and they
used derrick henry and that was the
shocking knockout of the season
yeah the only one of the teams with a
buy this year to lose in that divisional
round
it seems to happen you know like one a
year
uh for a while it was 50 50 proposition
more recently those teams with the buys
have won so that made it even more
stunning the ravens who seem to be the
team of destiny could not get past the
tennessee titans and what an afc
championship game that would have been
between the ravens and the chiefs i'm
gonna go one week earlier because i was
on record saying you can't kill the
terminator there's no way the titans are
going to go up to new england and end
the patriots run they've been in the afc
championship game every year since 2011.
they're not going to get knocked out in
the wild card round they're not going to
lose at home to the titans and the
titans went in there on a saturday night
and they they terminated the terminator
they took down the new england patriots
and i look it was a close game uh it was
it was a it easily could have gone
either way but the titans held it
together the titans came out of there
with the win and it's one of those that
i look i i admit i was wrong and i still
would pick the patriots if they were
playing again because we've seen what
the patriots can do in those single
elimination settings which i think made
what the titans did even more impressive
okay mike
decent pick but i have a better pick
because i'm gonna go
one week earlier from that and the miami
dolphins beating the patriots in
foxborough week 17 as 17-point underdogs
or whatever it was
absolutely stunning loss the patriots
never lose games like that they never
ever ever lose games like that tom
brady's record at home is eye-popping
and brian flores and ryan fitzpatrick
coming to foxboro they beat the patriots
and what did that do oh how about
decided the entire playoff picture and
how everything would unfold because if
the patriots win that game they have a
buy they don't lose to the titans your
knockout punch uh pick which was a bad
pick now that i'm saying it out loud
they lose they don't lose the titans
they get a bye they get a home home game
you know against maybe the chiefs who
they would play for the second time or
whoever else then they maybe go to
baltimore and play the ravens for a
second time bill belichick playing teams
a second time
the patriots could be sitting there in
miami looking at super bowl number seven
instead they lose to ryan fitzpatrick
and everything else changes and
everything else changes for the chiefs
who they get home field you know home
field advantage throughout the playoffs
with the ravens losing to the titans
that was the butterfly effect moment
that was the sliding doors moment that
was the knockout punch of 2019.
see now i'm not going to be a jerk like
you and just say i don't like your pick
i actually do like that pick it's okay
we're allowed to cooperate here it's
okay to try to get along i will say
you're not gonna like you're not gonna
like my third pick if that's your if
that's what you're thinking i
i don't like any of these picks from
this perspective none of the coaches of
any of these teams we've discussed got
literally knocked out as a result of the
knockout punch so i'm going to go a week
earlier
in week 17. i'm going to go to week 16
when the cowboys and the eagles got
together for what became the knockout
punch for america's team the cowboys all
the hype they started 3-0 they're
destined to make it to the playoffs and
then when it was clear that their
division is basically four crap teams
and all you have to be is the best of
four crap teams all the cowboys are
going to win the division no chance the
eagles are going to come back and win
this division no way all dallas and
philadelphia cowboys got this no big
deal cowboys win it cowboys win the
division and the eagles took them down
and jason garrett paid for it with his
job that is a knockout from 2019. okay
good pick mike good pick i'm gonna
compliment you that's a good pick my
third pick is actually me
throwing it to myself because we did
this draft all year round
we don't have the package but my third
pick is just me going against you
in these drafts
the mike florio getting knocked out week
after week after week credit to you mike
for getting up here you know what
because you're gonna say this is not a
real third pick i'll give you a slash
here and i'll give you a real third pick
and my draft beating you every single
week how about the knockout punch phil
rivers landed on chris jones how about
that
a literal knockout punch do we have a
[Laughter]
here's the thing
i did is there is there like a package
of like a montage of you
like like being a jerk to me during the
drafts that was set up ahead of time
that they were supposed to play
no what happened was and i'm not
throwing anyone under the bus because
everyone behind the scenes does a great
job there was so there was so much
footage of me wiping the floor with you
they didn't know what to do with it they
had to wheel it out like i said
in the old school nfl films they had to
wheel it out and it was like what do we
do with this there's so much the
anthology is so large so that was what i
just want to register my objection i was
betrayed by this no one told me about
this the control room has gone rogue we
got it we got a retiring let's go my
mortal enemy is written down i didn't
put it out there mike because i didn't
want to beat you too bad it's actually a
great pick because you know they're all
great the patriots they're all great oh
yeah i had byron wizard white yeah mike
no this is such a bad pick how do we do
the rest of this draft because i just
checkmated you with stats he's on the
ropes he's cut this is sad i won this
draft
there it is the knockout that wasn't a
very good montage again knocked yourself
out with that montage there's so much
that they could use and then uh slash uh
phillip rivers punching chris jones so
that's my third pick all right here's
mine here's mine now where did the
buster douglas mike tyson fight happen
japan
overseas wasn't in the united states so
i'm gonna go overseas for my next
knockout punch and it was fairly early
in the season but it was the moment that
we could become confident that a certain
defending division champion was
fraudulent it was when the
then oakland raiders
defeated the chicago bears in london and
we were stunned at the time how could
the bears lose to the lowly raiders the
bears are good well we would later find
out the bears weren't good but at that
moment at that moment right the bears
were a little mike tysony before then
but then the raiders were buster douglas
overseas wrong direction but overseas
and they knocked out the bears and
that's when we first were on notice that
maybe the bears weren't going to be very
good this year do you like that one you
just called the bears defending champs i
appreciate that
division champs division champs yeah no
that's a good pick mike good pick that
game still frustrates the heck out of me
uh but
i think that was one of those ones where
unlike mike tyson where he was a
deserved champion for many years it
probably showed
more flaws in what the bears are than
being an aberration loss
well and that's really the question for
me for the bears in 2020 which team is
going to show up the team that won the
division or the team that couldn't get
out of its own way for most of 2019.
we're going to get out of the way for a
few minutes let's recap the draft first
big cat's got the titans eliminating the
ravens from the playoffs as his first
round pick the dolphins beating the
patriots week 17 to keep them out of
their by him dominating me in every
draft of the year there's a shot i'm
shocked that he would wedge that in
rivers hitting chris jones which was far
from a knockout titans defeating
patriots as my first round pick that was
in the wild card round of the playoffs
eagles over the cowboys week 16 to knock
them out of the nfc east and then the
raiders exposing the bears as the frauds
they were by beating them in london
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports